a lot of people that assume that Oh
Trump is great for comedy Trump is great
for comedy and I've it's funny I've had
the reaction and I'm curious to get your
reaction I think I don't know I don't
know if he's great for comedy he's he's
certainly been great for some shows but
he's so much it's too much that to make
it's hard to even know how to make fun
of yeah what he's doing sometimes
because it's so absurd in and of itself
and it and it's also so rapid like like
having Trump as a comedian Trump is like
imagine there's a guy out on the
sidewalk and he's just taking a dump on
the pavement and he's yelling about
Hitler yeah and he's painting wallpaper
yeah and so you think of the funniest
joke about a guy taking a dump on the
sidewalk and you turn to tell your
friend and as you turned it to your
friend behind you
he is scooped up his poop and made his
sombrero out of it so you're about to
tell your friends like dude to heed me
he's moved on are you like oh my god so
it's like he is I describe him he is
sour cream in the sauna where he does
immediately good that there's no shelf
life and you're running towards it with
your chip like I'm gonna call it spoiled
[Laughter]
[Music]
it's look hey a Snickers bar is great
but 17 Snickers bar for dinner yeah not
that good yeah I just want you lost me
on that one
oh man that's my whatever meal
you